many of you a few days ago sent me video
of What appears to be Marjorie Taylor
green serving as Speaker of the House of
Representatives telling me that it made
you physically ill to see it
interestingly that is exactly the
headline that Newsweek selected for
their coverage of this bizarre event
called Marjorie Taylor green presiding
over house leaves viewers quote
physically ill now I want to make sure
everybody knows what did and did not
happen let's take a look at the video of
Marjorie Taylor green and then I will
tell you what this was all about
pursuant to the
to the Run Mr Westerman and the
gentleman General
each will control 20 minutes the chair
recognizes the gentleman from Arkansas
now many of you saw that and wrote to me
and said David is Marjorie Taylor green
now the speaker of the house she is not
the Speaker of the House what you have
to understand is that she briefly
presided over the house this is a role
called speaker pro tempore or sort of
means like for a little while and it's
frequently rotated it doesn't give you
you are not the Speaker of the House you
were temporarily presiding but it is
simply a
um it's a duty we could say it's an
assignment that you can be given
and she was not the speaker of the house
that being said it is disgusting and
very worrying that someone has unhinged
as Marjorie Taylor green is slowly
pulling herself closer to the mainstream
of the Republican Party a mainstream by
the way which is outrageously extreme
it's a mainstream that has become
extreme there was a segment on CNN about
this let's take a look at a little bit
of a margin Taylor green the Republican
congresswoman from Georgia re-elected in
November she has pushed baseless Q Anon
lies and conspiracies that include
saying that Democrats and celebrities
are part of a Satan worshiping pedophile
ring she has since tried to walk back
her involvement in Q Anon she also
questioned the events of 9 11 something
she's also tried to walk back
the so-called plane that crashed into
the Pentagon it's odd there's never any
evidence shown for a plane in the
Pentagon there is an Islamic Invasion
into our government offices right now
Kennedy getting killed in the plane
crash that's another one of those
um Clinton murders right so she has
pushed conspiracy that mass shootings
were staged and false listen you get the
point it is outrageous that someone who
has said the things Marjorie Taylor
green has said even got herself elected
okay but she did voters in Georgia
wanted her to represent them or at least
they thought they did but it is a new
level of absurdity that there is this
image even if it is only a very
temporary role a speaker pro tempore uh
presiding over the House of
Representatives I'm with you I'm with
you and the world sees it and they are
horrified how is it that in the United
States such a deranged individual can
achieve this level of power and
prominence and of course if you remember
what happened in 2016 with Donald Trump
the Marjorie Taylor green Fiasco all of
a sudden seems a lot less unlikely but
there it was we will almost certainly
see it again over the next couple of
years and then hopefully never again
after that it's a new year many of us
are trying to make new positive changes
here's something really simple that
could be a game changer our sponsor
athletic greens every day I take a scoop
of ag-1 I get 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients to last me all day long this
way I just know my nutritional bases are
covered for the entire day it has
everything I want and that's important
to me rather than doing the individual
supplements and vitamins or whatever
I don't want to do any of that okay ag1
is the simplest way to just get
everything I want for my nutritional
Foundation each day ag1 is also a great
bang for your buck you're going to end
up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and
minerals so save some money make your
life easier just a scoop of ag1 I love
the travel packs which let me take ag1
wherever I go I have the big pack of
ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below